[Música]
boa tarde
nós vamos estar 10
conhecemos o ano passado só o ano
passado agora somos finalistas não um
bar em viseu
eu estava a cantar caoc assim uma
brincadeira e aventura e também já
andava à procura de alguém para
acompanhar e eu também
escolhemos umas músicas começamos a
ensaiar e estamos juntos desde outubro
desde não temos por água e queremos
desde já agradecer o convite
temos atuado muitas vezes aqui na escola
e em mais nos acolhe e queremos mostrar
vos também o poder da nossa voz que é a
música
[Música]
cinza kevin barnes garante a onu
o irã amorim
além disso hora que eu
[Música]
sou eu
eu falei de marin
mano então
é
ah
a tinta ninguém na banda com a guerra
nem um animal
o irã de mar e mar em
então
nem
neymar
pra ninguém
ainda bem que o nome do jogo
[Música]
obrigada obrigada a buscar a paz técnica
decidiu aí vamos passar para uma em
português da ana moura o fado assim em
linha
quero do estilo que eu não ganha nunca
desistindo e o meu falou o neném
intervalo canta uma extensa isso quero
ter sentir sentimos como ninguém em não
ter sentido o gol
ai que tristeza nesta minha linda
melodia esta tão grande tristeza que
parar um dia eu não espero mais um dia
por aquilo que nunca mãe e quer que
esteve presente o tamanho do tempo
a mãe sofreu ainda dão poder cantar
não tem imagem do flamengo gostou de mim
cantar eu viver não está sempre a mãe só
por eu andar de um triz
você já a frança vai saborear andar
tanto lixo que eu tenho
ele está e não só por ser tão boa mãe só
por eu ainda amo muito obrigada